welcome to the United Kingdom visas and
immigration this is a rare insight into
Britain's overwhelmed immigration system
Eva is on the phone to the home office's
free phone hotline to claim Asylum
make an appointment to claim Asylum
please hold for an agent she arrived
five days ago in the back of a lorry
it seems to be very busy at the moment
Eva and her friend Dennis are both from
Albania a country which has seen a surge
in people trying to reach the UK Dennis
came a few months ago by small boat
they both say they want to speak to
break what they call the stigma of
criticism facing albanians why you want
to focus that migrants are a problem
problem problem start to see migrants as
a solution start to see us as worthy
people
the British government has said too many
albanians are abusing the system Dennis
and Eva say they can't face the future
in Albania and their lives there are
intolerable you're a stock broker who
found yourself in the back of a lorry
that's quite an extraordinary situation
isn't it yes because I mean it doesn't
make sense but when you look at Albania
and like the opportunities it gives to
you to young people
it will make sense if we have a proper
salary that will cover all our expense
and everything from there we wouldn't
leave from there some people would say
you're an economic migrant not an asylum
Seeker that the Asylum system is for
people who are fleeing things like war
and persecution I just want to live in a
happy environment you know I just want
to live in a safe environment I want to
live in a society that is well
structured you know and well organized I
don't want to live in chaos anymore
these pictures were filmed in the summer
within a few weeks of Dennis crossing
the channel the details he shared of his
journey reveal what Smuggler's tell
passengers to persuade them to join
criminal gangs in the UK they know that
the system is broken and they use this
as a strong point to convince people to
do this you'll never get a value of the
paper they tell to the albanians you
will never be integrated in the society
they've been like cases three year or
more they haven't even have the work
permit here yet like they tell you this
they convince you that you come here and
you cannot do nothing else
speaking to some Albanian migrants we
asked the government to comment on what
we've been told for many of the people
who come to these shows they're smuggled
here by organized criminal groups and
it's vitally important that we break
those organized criminal groups and
their means of operating Dennis and Eva
say they had no choice but to pay
Smugglers to change their lives they now
enter an asylum system that some waiting
for years to have their claims processed
Lisa Holland Sky News